communities throughout the dangerzone
are responding to that storm surge
threat people are pulling their boats
out of the water along the new river in
Jacksonville North Carolina it's one of
many cities expected to see the highest
storm surges when the hurricane makes
landfall Adriana Diaz is in Jacksonville
watching the preparations Adriana good
morning good morning the coastal on the
Carolinas has dozens of inlets that
funnel water into rivers like this one
so even though we're about 20 miles from
the Atlantic this area is expected to
get record storm surge that could go up
to 13 feet in the hardest hit areas
officials are making boat calls in
Jacksonville North Carolina thank
anybody on there
wildlife officers Taylor Cloninger and
Ryan bigger staff want this one moved
before the storm hits
it shouldn't be tied to the sign and
it's too close to nearby properties most
likely that boat is gonna go crashing
into these people's personal docks
they're causing a significant property
damage and boat could be a weapon in a
storm that's right yes
that's why as preps continue on shore
people are moving boats inland and
tucking away sails I look out here and
it looks really calm yeah we usually
it's just like glass really yeah you can
tell something's going on despite
appearances Jacksonville could get more
than two feet of rain in addition to
major storm surge it's really somewhat
of a gloomy feeling knowing that the
coast of North Carolina is gonna be
changed forever
the wildlife officers told us they're
also seeing animals on the move likely
sensing something's coming and moving to
higher ground now when this area gets
flooded they said alligators could be in
the flood waters as if people here don't
have enough to worry about
that's an aura point exactly like as if
they don't have enough to worry about
Adriana thank you